are you prepared to stand trial and
profess your guilt or innocence before
the seventh
we need to trust each other
with so many enemies now
phrase and the Lannisters send their
regards
I thought you knew what I wanted to tell
them what you did to it all you've
afraid good you're in the great game now
and the great game is terrifying
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones finale trailer
video just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far so here we go the funny thing
that happened this season is that HBO at
a certain point for the last couple of
episodes stop releasing information
synopsis but eventually we learned the
synopsis for the finale is just Cersei
faces her trial very simple obviously
there's a whole lot more going on and we
see that from the trailer that are using
the finale to wrap up all the big
ongoing storylines from this season ante
up what's gonna be happening next season
so just kind of moving the chess pieces
around the board on Westeros because
that's where most people are gonna be
the end of episode 9 is Daenerys is
leaving marine makes it sound like she's
not planning on coming back anytime soon
tell everyone what Daenerys did when she
came to marine and don't try to go back
to your slavers ways so it was like
Tyrion was giving the great master that
they left alive a warning if you don't
uphold the terms of your surrender no
more slavery we'll come back with the
dragons so it seems like the action for
the final two seasons I mean as far as
we know there's gonna be a season 7 in a
season 8 will take place in Westeros and
obviously moving closer and closer to
the north where ever the knight king's
army happens to be in the really
interesting thing about this trailer 2
is this reverse red wedding that they're
teasing with Jaime's character just like
he could not give a [ __ ] about Walder
Frey the Lannisters in the phrase send
their regards just this really horrific
twist on the red wedding so if you've
ever hoped for a Jaime Redemption this
is the moment to hope for a reverse red
wedding Catelyn Stark sends her regards
but on the flip side of that sergey's
character there was so much teasing of
Cersei storyline in episode 9 it was so
funny so in the first five minutes of
the episode Tyrion specifically mentions
the Wildfire that's hidden all over
King's Landing the story the Jaime told
him about the Mad King so he's like
Daenerys don't burn these cities don't
be like your father we don't want to go
that far I want to suggest an
alternative approach but it seems like
Cersei isn't going to listen to that
kind of reason so she is going to do
what Daenerys had planned to do whoa you
are going full Mad Queen so it seems
like sir she's gonna have her Mad Queen
moment because there is a big hidden
cache of wildfire underneath the great
Sept and that's where most of the action
for her storyline is gonna take place
but as I've mentioned before Cersei
is the protagonist of her own storyline
and we're viewing all this King's
Landing stuff through her eyes so don't
you feel like the Wildfire is her out
she'll come away with the big victory
but there'll be so much collateral
damage and so many good people will die
that she'll seem like a villain so the
show's really ambiguous at times about
what's good what's evil it's really all
about people's motivation the things
that they fight for how compelling their
characters are so while there is a
couple really big villains on the show
right now there's the night king
there's your on Greyjoy who's gonna be a
pretty fantastic villain and then
there's Cersei Lannister I will argue
that Cersei Lannister is gonna be the
best human villain on the show after
this season and like I said the finale
is kind of intended to create some
context for where the next season is
gonna pick up I think if anyone is gonna
have the job of taking Cersei down it
should be Jaime so you could tie that
into Maggy the Frog prophecy valonqar
but I think the idea with that like if
you're just going by the TV shows
version which is a slightly simpler
version that the book did they didn't
really do the valonqar on the TV show
but Maggie the Frog was telling sir see
that all these terrible things were
gonna happen to her but I think what the
finales gonna show us is that she's
going to have brung about all those
terrible things like ultimately she'll
be the cause of her own downfall the
death of all her children
so the Maggy the Frog prophecy is kind
of like a self-fulfilling prophecy at
least in the context of the TV show it's
a little more complex in the books but
what about Sansa and Littlefinger I know
a lot of people were confused about her
actions going into the Battle of
Winterfell like why didn't she tell Jon
about the alliance that she'd formed
with Littlefinger and what is the price
that he's going to extract from this
like she just didn't get all those
soldiers for free so logically I think
what Littlefinger's plan is is to marry
her to sweet Robin so that he can
control both of them
Sansa isn't quite as controllable as
sweet Robin sweet Robin's kind of a
human potato just like Tommen you can
pick them up and put them wherever you
want them they'll do whatever you want
them to do so little finger firmly has
the forces of the veil under his thumb
and I think now with this alliance with
Sansa he'll have the forces of the north
under his thumb too but not necessarily
in a sinister way I think if he had his
way he would put Sansa on the Iron
Throne with sweet Robin he would become
the new hand of the king and by proxy
control the Seven Kingdoms but the
problem is is if Cersei blows up half of
King's Landing with wildfire there
really isn't going to be in Iron Throne
and I think Daenerys is probably going
to realize
that that isn't the ultimate goal when
she gets to Westeros - so I think the
Iron Throne will become less of a
priority and it'll be more about uniting
the Seven Kingdoms against this bigger
threat of the night King what about Jon
Snow tower of joy reveal like why would
the show wait that long I mean it's a
great fan moment it's a bit of
fanservice because we've been expecting
it for so long but why would the show
save this for the very end well if you
think about what sir she's doing if
Tommen's collateral damage and there is
no king then there's no leadership in
right now Jon Snow now that he's
defeated Ramsay he probably isn't too
sure what he's gonna do it's not like
he's gonna take the black again so I
think the reveal is is meant to tea up
Jon Snow having a higher purpose in the
grand scheme of things like he's like
what am I supposed to do with my life
now I'm part of some giant prophecy so I
think the TV show might give him some of
the AEGON storyline from the books that
had cut out just someone as Varys says
with the right name and someone that the
people love so think about what Jon Snow
has done even Ramsay was like I've heard
stories about you and the great things
that you've done so that's probably
going to spread across the Seven
Kingdoms people will hear about the
awesome things that Jon Snow has done so
maybe fanfiction here Varys will try to
rope him into the Targaryen restoration
but what about brans storyline he's
gonna be facing the knight King at the
wall I think we're gonna see him
activate some of his new powers that he
hasn't played around with as the new
last green seer so I think we're gonna
see bran do some really cool stuff and
they'll do a pretty good job of
foreshadowing what's gonna be happening
with the night's king next season tyrion
talking about the Wildfire like
specifically mentioning wild fire
underneath bail or cept in episode 9 is
a good example of how the show just like
slaps you in the face with stuff that
it's going to be doing in the future so
I think they're gonna do a good job of
that in episode 10 you'll have a really
good idea for what's going to be
happening in the first couple of
episodes next season so I'll just
actually I'll say there's a new round of
the giveaway this week all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll announce
the winner when I post my Q&A video and
like another day or two but I also
wanted to say what's going to be
different about this year obviously the
the finales called winds of winter but
winds of winter the book is supposed to
come out sometime it might not come out
till the end of the summer but when it
does I will do videos about book things
so we can compare some of the moments
like the Hodor hold the door moment they
said that the way that
going to play out in the books is gonna
be very different so I'll do videos like
that whenever that book comes out but
that might not be for a couple more
months so the bonus videos I do for the
TV show will depend a lot on what you
guys want to talk about and then
whenever the book drops we can talk
about book stuff it'll be a lot of fun
there's a whole bunch of really cool
book stuff that the show's never gonna
have time to touch but this weekend this
week we'll have a lot of fun talking
about how the show is metaphorically
burning down the practices of the old
the old way of doing things
to make way for the new and then how
it's literally burning things down like
the nares burning the cows and then
hopefully saying wildfire burned down a
lot of King's Landing so while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for last night's episode 9
video and you can click here for a tower
of joy refresher thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you